m
[Musique]
c'est déjà beau frère aîné
ah oui c'est des bons moments
[Musique]
je suis apte alors c'est parce qu'ils ne
sont pas tous deux matchs de la dame à
l'hermine complet
ah bon vraiment 20 ans blessé par
intermittence enfin temps en temps je
reste quelques mois sans vieillir je
reviens après parce que j'ai toujours
une ambiance étrange
parlez moi
comme je veux voir combien 5 francs oui
mais pour tout le repas et le service
est compris dit non mais ça n'est pas
cher cinq ans elle tout et c'est
vraiment incroyable
voilà comment trouver la cuisine et ça
vous étonne quand même que l'on puisse
servir un menu à 5 francs j'encadre
alain en plein paris soit ces connards
pour mais je vous l'avais dit on n'avait
pas cru d'ailleurs il a longtemps mené
simon 50 50
et comment trouvez vous aidera pas et
bien pas un jeu propre et pour un
ouvrier comme nous c'est bien parce que
sinon pour charpente ou payet 5 points
on sent même pas un casse croûte
qu'est ce que vous avez mangé réellement
changer un peu le riz les gens qui ont
un restaurant en général ils augmentent
les prix pour les américains alors que
vous profitez de la clientèle américaine
à cinq alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire comment vous faites pour faire un
menu à 500 avait beaucoup de volonté oui
vous êtes aidez clandestinement par le
cheval vous envoie un chèque à la fin je
[Musique]
vais leur expliquer expliquer moi parce
que je suppose que les français ne
peuvent pas comprendre comment faites
vous vos achats harry mateer 30e
oui tant qu'ils demandent ya 30 ans
jamais ça va gentiment et vous
réussissez vous réussissez à acheter à
faire cuire a présenté dans un local qui
n'est pas mal avec l'électricité le gaz
tout un menu pour cinq fois donné alors
que leur assise à l'ennemi
oui ça va m'enlever oui mais pas les
bras mais comme les achats m oui
puisqu'on vous faites vos achats tous à
la vie de mme astié rue des martyrs donc
toutes les ménagères qui vont à la rue
des martyrs devrait faire d'un marché
américain est retombé au maghreb arabe
et a quand même temps y'a combien de
temps il va correspondre est ouvert
cantine pour les ouvriers pour il ya 25
ans pour la première fois ici mais c'est
pas d'aujourd'hui et ça a toujours été
dans les mêmes prix du pourquoi non
quand même pas ça va les deux tranchants
qu'à l'époque l'école instant quand
j'avais 15 ans et maintenant 82 5 francs
voilà je suis là je me situe lui à paris
de toute façon tout le monde fasse je
vais moi même légère voler sa 7ème 12 79
pour le 14 juillet ne suis pas vous dire
qu'est ce que 10 20 mais je suis tout ça
c'est pour moi puisque envahie de kasami
des garanties de ville saint georges
alors je sais que c'est vraiment là moi
même il ya plein de quartier pour comme
ça chez believe sur moi tranquillement
voyons maintenant les américains c'est
qu'on mette en ajouter est ce assez pour
l'année 82 81 m alors c'est ce que nous
devons faire une telle déclaration
ah oui alors vous avez toute la france
que vous écouterez plaisir qui promet
des garanties que pendant l'année canal
sat management et les pales depuis que
tout le monde le dit moi j'ai chez moi
menu en france avec talent conflit il
serait d'ailleurs pas trop mal le
sourire
[Applaudissements]
à la mutuelle
si vous pouviez faire la même chose avec
les sens les automobiles mais il ya
secret ou non vous faites vraiment votre
marché rue des martyrs mais mamie gouel
on peut pas vous reprocher d'avoir
augmenter vos prix il ya 15 ans l'un de
vos plus fidèles clients le disait
c'était de francs 60 et puis aujourd'hui
ces cinq francs vous avez mis le prix du
menu à 500 pour faire un chiffre rond ou
parce que sinon vous ne rentrez pas ça
pour être moins cher
oh oui il ya des clients qui se
plaignent ah non eh bien je crois que
madame madame li guo elle a réussi plus
forte la baguette un formidable order
lagarde y voit mal des serres dans les
services compris cinq ports pour un bond
dans le big one
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]